one and one and that was in his last
start his first big league win
high fast ball again and that's one of
the keys to ober's success
it's 93 it's upstairs
your adversary breaking ball quicker one
that's swinging a miss
scope down on strikes and now robbie
grossman
three strikeouts what turned out to be a
harmless single and stolen base a
scoreless first for bayley over
we want the funk chef because he's been
nasty here of late
he's got a three pitch mix as well
he struck him out climbed the ladder got
him to chase
two away princess two hits
in the game yesterday pinch hitting for
nomar mizara
turns on this one deep to right field
gone
nico goodra deposits one and on the
right field bleachers his sixth homer of
the year the tigers
have drawn first blood in minnesota good
at bat
kept it alive and just whipped it into
right field
quite the battle with bayley over and he
hits a line drive home
run into the seats that overhang the
field in right to give the tigers a
one-nothing lead in the second
short originally was going to get the
day off
the 2-2 turns on one sends it to deep
left field
lardak is back he's at the wall he leaps
it's gone
back-to-back bombs good room and now
short two-nothing tigers really good
swing here by
zach short and what's impressive about
it chef it's with two strikes
that tells you that the tigers are
shortening up with two strikes and
they're taking those a swings
on mistakes one block allowed by kyle
funkhouser so far
now the one-two to simmons on the
outside corner to get him looking
second strikeout of the day for kyle
funkhouser he keeps it right where it
was when he first took the mound
it's two nothing his day ends after two
and a third and 51 pitches
daniel norris will come in with his best
is done for the second out in the third
here is carol off
two on and two out one two man he struck
him out
daniel norris gets kiriloff on the
slider away
i like castro though in this situation
here
here it comes in the hole and out of the
reach
of anderton simmons haas will hustle and
score
the tigers have added to their lead
thanks to the rbi single from harold
castro
and now zach short tries to fight off
derek law
strike one he swings it's a high fly
ball left center this would get the run
home over as kepler to make the catch
tagging candelario
haas was heading to secondary goodwin
was heading to second one back to first
sacrifice fly for zach short good
situational hitting
tigers take a four nothing lead here in
the fourth here's a rasmus ramirez
well chef he's going to crisscross the
strike zone with a firm fastball at 94
miles per hour
1-2 grounded to third nice backhand play
by harold castro
on a hop to jonathan scope to get miguel
cino
nice read here by harold castro
not your everyday third baseman so
that's what for me makes it impressive
but he
can glove it goes down one knee gets up
in a hurry
let's go that ball and i like that he
does this ship a little bounce across
the diamond gets that ball there
tough play arise crossing the line
firing and he makes a great play to get
eric haas he ended up near home plate by
the time his momentum
finished went away you don't necessarily
work on these
plays you get ground balls hit back at
you but see how he
shuffles his feet to make sure he had
his
balance now i saw something that
might be noteworthy here i've never seen
it before greg gibson in the middle of
danny coulomb's warm-up tosses came out
to the mound
and checked his cap and now there's a
conference between
gibson and rocco baldelli i've never
seen an umpire do that
in the middle of the warm-up tosses and
the manager will go to the mound here
and along with greg gibson
just make sure that he actually did
switch caps i guess
they got him picked off so no double
clutches his throw
but right there for the tag
polanco so a pick off ends the inning
and we head to the bottom of the six
carol off with a grounder to first in a
strikeout
kirilov hits the first pitch high in the
air right centerfield get up get out of
here go
it's a whole run to the upper deck and a
two-run shot for alex kiriloff
after stranding a pair in the first and
stranding a pair in the third
alex kiriloff plays a pair here in the
sixth inning it's a 4-2 ball game
now polanco had a great month of june
might have been the twins best hitter in
june
and the 1-0 pitch a drive to right field
and deep becket goes
gone twins take the lead
on a line drive homer to right from
polanco
one swing of the bat it's now 5-4
twins bottom seven three straight hits
capped off by a
go ahead three run homer from the former
all-star
shortstop that was a fastball inside in
95 at the knees polacco got the bet
going quickly
and barreled it up to the right field
corner
boss is over two with a walk and a run
scored
got him looking the fourth seamer at 95.
two away
got him
and now the ever patient arise with the
bases already loaded
to the left
two runs will score and there's your
breathing room
why don't that bat outside the strike
zone
not gonna caught get caught looking at
it and pokes it down the left field line
a three-run home run from the left side
of the plate now hitting right-handed
to the backstop here comes a runner on
the ball
fumbled by haas and simmons will score
and here comes another run to score
time wasn't called and the tigers just
stood there
and arise never stopped running or if he
did he was told to head home by
tony diaz
and a fastball day in the game nice come
from behind win
by the twins again today nothing going
offensively in the first half of the
game
rocco baldelli must have a heck of a
halftime speed